[Musica]
sono d'acqua di mohamed tunisino de roma
come si dice
nata in tunisia nel deserto del sahara
tunisino profondo sud della tunisia è
cresciuta da sempre nota per ferire
umana anche se ho perso tantissimo il
ghiaccio anto romano perché studiato qui
a firenze per tre anni e mi occupo di
graphic journalism
oggi volevo raccontarvi una storia e
storie a proposito di ombre di ombre che
hanno fatto parte della mia vita fin da
bambina a partire ombre negative e ombre
positive ma ombre negative da cui ho
tratto sempre il lato positivo perché mi
hanno formato
e mi hanno cresciuta e hanno reso la
taqwa di oggi ecco a partire da dalla
mia prima infanzia sono nata e cresciuta
in una famiglia di attivisti insegnanti
delle scuole professori universitari e
matt i visti per i diritti umani
purtroppo sotto la dittatura di ben ali
che
diciamo che è durata per tantissimi anni
e che ci ha privato della nostra libertà
di espressione della nostra diciamo vita
quotidiana addirittura perché mio padre
era stato esiliato nel 91 quattro mesi
dopo la mia nascita e mia mamma è
rimasta con sei figli e due suoceri e
una famiglia a cui doveva badare da sola
nel profondo sud della tunisia e
che ha lottato con questa ombra che
invece è rimasta
parte del nostro quotidiano che era la
polizia ben ali era un di diciamo un ex
ministro degli interni quindi era
dittatore ma una dittatura di polizia
mi ricordo della polizia che veniva ogni
almeno una volta a settimana a casa
nostra a rompere tutto buttare tutto
fuori ma mia mamma era lì impassibile a
proteggere i suoi figli noi sono laser
stadi a di sette figli l'ultimo e romano
de roma nato a roma non ha mai
conosciuto questa parte io lo chiamo al
bambino fortunato ecco mamma invece è
l'ombra positiva nella mia vita perché
nonostante la dittatura da un lato ci
portava via tutto mia mamma era sempre
lì presente in silenzio tutto ciò che ci
portavano via loro cioè mamma ma loro lo
ricompensa va dalla da un lato ecco io
sono stata sempre appassionata di
disegno fin dalla mia prima infanzia è
stato il mio primo mezzo di
comunicazione quando sono arrivato in
italia
comunicavo con le mie maestre disegnando
un pater quando volevo andare in bagno
mi capiva perfettamente un linguaggio
molto universale ecco quando la
dittatura ci portava via i miei blocchi
di disegno le nostre cose mio amo e mi
comprava sempre anche quando non aveva
neanche una lira mi comprava sempre un
blocco da disegno per potermi esprimere
perché era quello il mio mezzo di
comunicazione quando sono arrivato in
italia mi ha seguito un'altra ombra
negativa l'ombra del era 99 dopo due
anni sono successi gli attentati
dell'undici settembre del 2001 quindi ho
dovuto prendere delle decisioni nella
mia vita proprio per rispondere a una
domanda del chi sono io che mi ha
perseguitato per tutta la mia vita
quando sono arrivata qui ero
convintissimo di essere italiani romana
de roma e invece c'è stato il mio
compagno di banco lazzi fascista
dichiarata come un banco diviso in due
obbligati a stare in banca insieme nella
sua meta di banco c'era una svastica
nazista e lui mi diceva tu sei un
immigrata tu sei un immigrati di suoni
sono romano come te
e niente lui
il foglio col bollato positivo invece
della sua presenza nella mia vita che
era una presenza molto negativa ma il
lato positivo che lui mi ha diciamo mia
mi ha fatto capire un lato della mia
identità che io continuavo a ignorare o
mettere da parte perché gli altri
potevano pensare male mi vergognavo di
questa mia identità del mio essere
tunisina che rinnega vo del quando
parlava in arabo con con la mia famiglia
per strada o sull'autobus mi vergognavo
della mia della mia lingua madre di una
delle mie due lingue madri quindi lui è
stato una presenza molto importante
nella mia vita anche se ci insultavamo a
vicenda ma quello insultarsi a vicenda
siamo poi cresciuti insieme abbiamo
abbattuto quel muro che è stato molto
facile costruirlo ma a batterlo è stato
di una difficoltà immensa di un superare
le non solo e le sue bandiere ma anche
le mie i miei pregiudizi nei suoi
confronti
lui mi insultava mi diceva immigrata gli
davo del fascista e non sapevamo nessuno
dei due cosa significavano queste parole
quindi
mi ha insegnato mi ha fatto riconoscere
una parte della mia identità
poi è arrivata un'altra ombra che mi ha
fatto capire invece l'importanza del mio
essere donna una e le mie scelte in
quanto donna ho avuto un insegnante
questa storia la raccontano il mio
ultimo libro il mio migliore amico e
fascista e
questa insegnante era si dichiarava
femminista ma con una visione del
femminismo molto euro centri che è molto
ristretta che non riconosceva gli altri
femminismi era per me è la prima volta
che entrava in contatto con questa
parola e avevo 14 anni
però colto lato positivo lei mi diceva
sei stato obbligato a portare il velo
gli dicevo nessuno mi ha obbligato anzi
i miei genitori erano proprio contrari a
questa mia decisione
no allora sei stata influenzata dalla
società quale società vivo nella sua
stessa società sono cresciuta qui di che
cosa stiamo parlando
ho iniziato a capire quali sono i miei
diritti in quanto donna ho iniziato a
cogliere un'altra visione del mio del
femminismo che ho fatto mia quindi per
me le persone queste ombre negative che
sono apparse nella mia vita ma erano
fondamentali per me che che passano no
nel percorso di vita che ho vissuto
perché hanno fatto di me la persona che
sono oggi
è invece in ombra positiva che diciamo
che è ancora tutt'oggi un'ombra che mi
seguono mi sostiene quella è stata mia
mamma mia mamma con con la sua grande
forza mi ha ispirato tantissimo nella
mia vita e per esempio
quando mi dicevano vai affari
l'artistico sei bravissima disegnare set
regione che cavolo ci faccio con l'arte
nella mia vita
finirò disoccupato invece oggi il mio
mio principale lavoro i miei genitori mi
spingevano mi dicevano vai a fare
l'artistico studia arte perché ogni
mezzo di comunicazione è anche un mezzo
artistico quindi era importante per loro
seguire che io seguisse le mie passioni
e i miei sogni anche se io stessa li
mettevo da parte mi spingevano a
seguirli e questa è stata una cosa
veramente molto molto importante per me
anche se le persone che circondavano la
famiglia dicevano ma no che cosa ci fai
con l'arte il fumetto è una roba per
bambini
vai a fare la sarta o studia qualsiasi
altra cosa
io dicevo no il fumetto mi mi porterà in
giro per il mondo
lo dicevo anche se io stesso non ero
convinta miei genitori n'erano più
convinti e così è stato il fumetto mi ha
portato in giro per il mondo a superare
in sempre di più le mie le mie barriere
le mie i miei limiti
mi ha portato in cambogia fare vorrei
portare sul traffico di essere umani
un tema che io stessa non conosceva mi
ha portato in indonesia nel sud est
asiatico come in america in africa
quindi è sempre
un qualcosa che mi porta a crescere
prima di fare comunicazione per per gli
altri quindi è la storia di di ombre che
continuano a far parte della mia vita ma
io sono arrivata a oggi ha trent'anni e
e cogliere questo lato positivo di
queste ombre perché appunto come dicevo
prima sono essenziali se corriamo sempre
il lato positivo di ogni cosa negativa
che ci succede nella nostra vita sono
nata nel deserto del sahara nel profondo
sud senza niente che l'avrebbe mai detto
che oggi sarei stata qui su questo palco
a parlare di questa storia se non fosse
stata per la dittatura che è stata
motivo per cui noi ci siamo trasferiti
in italia se non fosse stato per tanti
altri serie d di persone che mi hanno
portata hanno segnato il mio percorso
probabilmente oggi non sarei qui a
parlare con voi quindi
grazie io credo sempre che una cosa che
amo dire perché ci credo fortemente
oggi come oggi sentiamo molto ma
ascoltiamo poco io vorrei veramente
ringraziare tutte le persone che si
impegnano ad ascoltare veramente ciò che
gli altri hanno da dire perché è una
cosa molto molto importante andare oltre
ci porta ad andare oltre alle alle
barriere alle barriere estetiche alle
barriere visive e conoscere le storie di
ognuno perché ogni giorno incontriamo
persone per strada no al supermercato
alle poste
sull'autobus in m
ma quanto sappiamo di queste altre
persone ognuno di noi c'è una storia
importante da raccontare che lascia il
segno che lascia il segno
negli altri come così le storie degli
altri lasciano un segno su di noi quindi
volevo veramente un grandissimo grazie
per per ascoltarsi oggi tutti quanti
e un grazie per gli organizzatori perché
è un evento molto molto importante per
me questo grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]